we got a lot of good news for you guys
get those black pills out of your mouths
the first big story is that a judge has
ruled in favor of Andy no an alleged
antifa members must pay him a combined
300 000 over damages in the Portland
attack so we'll go through that that's a
tremendous Victory we also have an
anti-trump Democrat arsonist who set
fire to a trump sign twice has been
identified reported to the police and
according to Benny Johnson his his
Source says this man has admitted his
crimes we put up a reward to catch this
guy after a local man posted Nest video
footage showing this anti-trump bike
bicyclist setting fire to a house where
he knew he could cause massive damage
potentially take lives and now uh we
caught the guy so that's the the really
really good news there's a lot more in
the big news you've got Donald Trump's
bail being said at two hundred thousand
dollars so we'll get into that in a bit
we're learning more about Hunter Biden
and allegations